foreign
Jared in Baltimore hey Jared welcome to
the show
hey George hey Rachel I am giant fan of
the show I've been watching every day
um you guys definitely set me up for my
financial life I actually started taking
the course in high school and so yeah
I'm 25 now wow
um yes so I wanted to ask a question
um but I think I didn't really see a
good answer on so I'm looking to upgrade
my car I have a 2006 Toyota Corolla
that's awesome and it's still it's still
chicken but uh it's got 150 000 miles
and that's it I'm looking forward to the
future George stop Sheriff needs a new
car if he's been doing this since he was
in high school he's going to be fine I
was impressed because it's an 06. it
should have more miles than that so
that's pretty good it's pretty cool
okay Jared well way to go man at 25
driving on 06. that takes so that takes
a lot of swallowing your price George
and I graduated high school
you've been following this stuff since
high school and so hopefully you have no
debt in an emergency fund
absolutely I love it um and I make about
80 000 a year love it uh and I have
about 40 saved and my question is I I
know I've heard Dave you know he he
tells us to not purchase a car more than
half of our annual income but it still
just feels like a lot
um spending 40 so I was like I was
looking at the market and especially
right now like used cars are so crazy I
know it's going down but
um like what would be a number that you
guys would see just given my income and
how much I have to save and no debt um
how much would you guys feel safe
I mean you're you're right on with your
parameters there but again forty
thousand dollars when you've been
driving an 06 Corolla you feel like
you're you're gonna buy a Maserati so do
you have a car in mind I would more
focus on what what's the car that I
would like to buy and then what year
make model mileage am I looking at to
get it within a decent parameter so
that's how we look at this is just those
ratios we just don't want too much of
your world tied up in a car yeah because
it's forty thousand dollars includes
your emergency fund Jared like is all of
that or is this just for a car
specifically oh no this is just this is
just for a car like and do you have any
other upcoming goals are you in a house
are you wanting to put a down payment
yeah that's the thing like that was the
other thing that was fooling around in
my head was like settling down and
getting into a house but I mean I'm kind
of in a situation right now where um I'm
dating somebody and we're getting pretty
close to marriage and so like I don't
know if I want to settle down for a
house just yet no you don't need to buy
a house right now but the question is
how much of that could be used towards a
down payment
and in 12 months in 12 months 12 to 18
to two years from now when you have 20
000 sitting there and you bought a
twenty thousand dollar car
exactly yeah and that's kind of an idea
I've been throwing around they um you're
probably gonna laugh but the car I want
is just another Corolla yes great you
don't laugh at that that was mine that
has my heart I love Toyota I was driving
a Honda Civic and my dream was a Honda
Accord that was me really dreaming big
and it's a I mean that's a great car so
I haven't seen what those cost
yeah so I wanted the new crossover that
they made uh and I think they start at
around 30
um for brand new but obviously like I
could get the I think they're they're
pretty new so I mean I think the oldest
I could get is like a two-year-old used
one and I think those run between 30 and
35 but like I said you know the used car
Market's kind of crazy but would you
guys recommend spending less like you
said in saving some of it it just
depends on how so if you have no current
plans to get into that house and
obviously you have that savings muscle
built up so when it comes time for you
to get that down payment I think you're
gonna do it really quickly and so I'm
not as worried about that I think a
thirty thousand dollar car is reasonable
for how hard you've worked and how
diligent you've been so the what I don't
want you to do is feel guilty after you
buy it and have you know buyer's remorse
because you've you've earned this man
you're doing it the right way
hey can I get it for 30 instead of 35
let me try to really do my research do
my due diligence and find that that
quote deal and of course make sure you
get a pre-purchase inspection uh and
don't fall for any of their warranties
and fees and all these things are adding
on yeah because the hard thing is even
if the brand new one's 30 so much of the
markup right now still within
dealerships is still insane so
um yeah finding something that is
reasonable probably used
um how much do you think you can get for
your for your current car
yeah you know I thought about that too I
mean it's in pretty good shape I looked
at the Kelly Blue Book I mean I think
it's like around 6 000 so which is
awesome yeah which makes you're going to
be spending you know 24 to 28 on this
thing out of pocket
yeah true so that'll make you feel a
little bit better about it but I I would
not feel guilty you're still gonna have
money left over for a down payment that
you can then stack on top of that you've
done this thing so well man you're just
a like the poster child of what it looks
like to follow these steps early well
done Jared some people take the high
school class and they just laugh at us
make fun of us don't listen oh yeah go
rack up a bunch of debt and you Jared
you listens and now you get to go by you
reap the new car because you have no
debt you have a fully funded emergency
fund and you are just killing it it's
awesome